While some businesses are turning cautious...
...in the face of global economic gloom,...
...Ikea is banking on consumers searching for more value for money.
Its owners, Inca Group, is spending 3.2 billion dollars through 2023,...
...much of it to modify its out of town outlets...
...so they can also handle e-commerce distribution.
A third of the cash is earmarked for London and the UK,...
...a test bed for new store formats and logistics.
Inca wants to invest in automation and ship online purchases...
...directly from certain stores,...
...which they say will make deliveries faster, cheaper and lower emissions.
Over the past two years of disruption and lockdowns,...
...Ikea saw record demand for its cut-price home furnishings.
It's already invested over 2 billion dollars...
...while adapting to the rise in online shopping.
And now, as customers feel the spending squeeze,...
...Inca says that timing for Ikea couldn't be better.